welcome to hurry sobbing the channel
will be discussed the latest tech news
and da Vinci newest tech products so
today we're taking a look at why GPU
prices are dropping really slowly and
where the future of GPU prices are
headed but before we get into that make
sure to hit that subscribe button if you
guys like to stay updated with the
latest tech news related to gaming and
pcs so fortunately for us the GPU crisis
had finally started to drop and GPUs are
finally being offered for reasonable
prices however at the same time they
have been dropping in price for many
months so why is that for example during
the last four months on average the GTX
1066 gigabyte card only dropped one
dollar every single day and gtx 1070 is
even worse that card only got 50 cents
every day over the past 4 months the GTX
1084 the last couple of months has been
dropping on an average of $2 a day
finally the gtx 1080i has had the
greatest luck while at first it was a
300 or 400 overpriced has been dropping
at $4 to $5 every single day so what
about the red team are their prices
doing any better well unfortunately for
them the same story applies there are
GPUs have been dropping at an average
rate of about one to two dollars over
the past 4 months so as it is clear GPU
prices are dropping at a very slow rate
so what could possibly be causing this
well let's take a look at all the issues
that could be leading to this a couple
of months ago everybody would simply
point to miners and blame it on them
however now the mining craze that was
initially there has subsided and
everyone who is still mining has moved
on to a6 or has completely quit mining
all together and soldered GPUs on Amazon
or Ebay so mining isn't really affecting
the scene anymore so is it a stock issue
or Nvidia and AMD not producing enough
GPUs to meet the market demand well not
really so what about RAM prices Ram
definitely has the potential to affect
the GPU market and hold GPU prices for
hitting MSRP however they would not
cause GPU prices to drop out of slower
rate
they make hold GPU prices back from
hitting MSRP but I really doubt they
would slow the rate down for example
when the gtx 1070 and 1080 launched it
cost nvidia and AMD about forty to fifty
dollars to get eight gigabytes of gddr5
vram now it cost them a hundred dollars
to get that same ram so that is a $60
increase but that would just lead to a
simple $60 increase on MSRP side as well
it wouldn't lead to a slower drop in
prices so overall at this point
everything that we have been blaming for
the last couple of months for holding
back GPU prices from hitting MSRP aren't
really calling GPU prices to drop at a
slower rate than normal so what is the
real reason that it's causing this well
in my opinion the real reason that GPU
prices are dropping in such a slow rate
is actually ourselves the fact that many
of us are willing to buy GPUs overpriced
is what is actually influencing the
slowdown fall and that is why the prices
are falling at a faster rate for GPUs
that are less often purchased like the
GTX 1080 and 1080 Ti
because for those cards there are less
people willing to buy them and as a
result retailers can't really sustain
over price situations for very long so
as a result retailers are more likely to
bring the price down so for cars like
the GTX 1060 and 1070 however there are
a lot of people willing to buy those
cards and there are a lot of people who
are willing to pay inflated prices as
well and so for those cards retailers
are able to maintain inflated prices and
still get a lot of sales and that is why
those are dropping out of the slower
rate
why would retailers lower their price
when there are still selling really well
at a higher price this also explains two
random price drops that occur from the
gtx 1060 and 1070 it's not like the gtx
1060 is consistently dropping one dollar
every single day this is what actually
happens the price of the gtx 1060 sees
no fluctuation for around 10 to 15 days
and suddenly one day
it drops ten to fifteen dollars and this
is because one retailer decides to go
for more sales by lowering their
and then all the other retailers catch
up and then it goes to that price and
that price maintains for a couple of
weeks and the same thing happens again
and this is what we have been seen with
the GTX 1060 and 1070 for the last
couple of months and so this would
perfectly explain it so where is this
leading to and will GPUs ever hit MSRP
then well there is the issue of RAM but
I think that GPUs volka MSRP despite the
rim pricing situation right now because
in November and December of last year
GPUs were at MSRP however the RAM
pricing situation was pretty much just
as bad
so obviously the retailers are able to
offer their GPUs for MSRP
despite the RAM pricing situation that
we are seeing right now so in my opinion
our willingness to overpay for GPUs or
actually what are holding GPUs back from
MSRP if you look at the GTX 1080 and
1080 Ti well the GTX 1080 is already
well below MSRP at $550 and oftentimes
even less and a gtx 980ti has been
rapidly dropping and it is about to hit
MSRP and it's only about 20 to 30
dollars over MSRP right now so for those
cards that it is unsustainable to
maintain inflated prices for retailers
those cards are going down at a faster
rate and hitting MSRP however for the
cards where retailers are able to
maintain inflated prices and still sell
really well those cards are suffering
from it but that's just what I think
feel free to comment down below why I'm
wrong and what things I'm overseeing so
how do you guys feel for example are you
furious at the people who are buying
GPUs for inflated prices which is not
only costing them extra money but making
the GPU situation worse for everyone or
do you already have the GPU that you
want and you could care less about this
whole situation and you're just sitting
at home laughing make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments I'm curious as
to what you guys think so make sure to
post your thoughts also if you guys like
this video that makes your drop a like
and hit that subscribe button if you
guys would like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time bye
[Music]